la policía llegó para velar por su
seguridad
pero son los mismos trabajadores de la
ong quienes están llevando a cabo la
redada
ar sat con la camisa roja es el líder de
la operación sabe que el equipo debe
moverse con mucha rapidez después de
varias misiones indagatorias ar sat está
convencido de que unos niños están
siendo utilizados como esclavos en una
fábrica textil en las afueras de nueva
delhi esta es una operación de rescate
otro
saquen ese camión del camino
arzo reconoció rápidamente un niño
primero que todo llévense a este
tiene 12 años y ha estado reparando
llantas en el garaje
y los demás vayan por el otro
los talleres que se encuentran en este
edificio son el objetivo principal
los primeros pisos están casi vacíos
pero justo en los últimos encuentran
siete niños trabajando con máquinas de
textura
sangraba con su celular reunión de
evidencia no nos vamos de año
cuando te llamas
dicen tener 10 y 16 años han sido
obligados a trabajar aquí 6 días a la
semana desde las 9 de la mañana hasta
las nueve de la noche comiendo y
durmiendo en el agua
me gusta se llama
y ahora qué
krishna bola
ah
o el hombre al que se refieren como su
dueño es el traficante que lo sacó de su
pueblo
a menudo se trata de redes de crimen
organizado que le prometen a padres
afectados por la pobreza que le están
dando a su hijo una mejor oportunidad de
vida luego se los llevan y los volvieron
a trabajar como esclavos
también fue ahora la policía cerrará la
fábrica y todos estos niños comparecerán
ante el tribunal de valoria se les harán
exámenes médicos y serán revisados luego
lo llevaremos a su casa y nos
mantendremos
los niños son sacados están visiblemente
ansiosos pero son negros un hombre que
se encontraba con ellos en el taller es
arrestado y retirado en una motocicleta
la organización que lideró la operación
están lejos de haber hecho su primera
redada
fundada en 1980 que ya ha conseguido
rescatar alrededor de 90.000 niños
esclavizados en india
su nombre es batman patch wonderland
literalmente el movimiento de rescate
infantil tres de sus miembros han muerto
durante las misiones y muchos otros han
sido heridos por traficantes
su fundador kailash satyarthi recibió el
premio nobel de la paz en 2014
my only in life
mi único objetivo en la vida es que cada
niño sea libre de ser un niño por encima
de todo sea libre de soñar
después de ser liberados los niños son
cuidados en este centro mientras esperan
a ser reunidos con sus familias
la idea es reintroducir los de manera
gradual a una vida normal ayudarnos a
volver a confiar ya que puedan sentirse
felices
comienzan muchachos
siguen estando muy vulnerables
nos obliga a que la marcha de apoyo
el sap de lino
de una casa
por esos delitos
[Música]
una vez que regresan a sus casas los
niños son monitoreados por la ong hasta
que cumplen 18 años para asegurarse de
que no vuelvan a caer en las manos de
los traficantes en índia se estima que
actualmente alrededor de 10 millones de
niños son forzados a trabajar